the first album is normally the one that
people self-titled because it's the
introduction that didn't for whatever
reason crossed my mind but every album I
think kind of it carries the theme of
that that chapter and so the first time
was the first time I did anything
unapologetically with me taking
ownership of my life and in career and
love really and this one is called
Kelsey because I feel like it's the
album that is super self-aware and super
open and a different way than I've been
before and it's like the album that I
keep saying like puts me on first name
basis with everyone
honestly I don't know I don't know what
to expect I think that we're gonna hear
car songs I have a feeling that we're
gonna hear LA I just feel like we need
to have a good kick-off party
so welcome to the kick-off party riding
with the Jillian Michaels and the Taylor
parks and the edge insurance just they
have such an incredible lyric country
sensibility too so it never even worried
me that we weren't gonna write a country
song cuz they're just great lyricist but
yeah and being able to write with I mean
some of the best songwriters in the
world this time around again it just
pushed me
start show
[Music]
even though
[Applause]
the whole thing is me trying to be
self-aware it's a lot of self-discovery
and a lot of it is still unsure like
even the first song overshare it's like
I am loud and I talk too much and I'm
always doing stuff and it's really
because oh I'm scared of the silence I'm
scared of alone time now I'm aware of
that
maybe I'll change that now and like
maybe the next album will be me changing
that like I don't know but the last two
years it's just been me really like
getting to know myself
[Applause]
it's all day today
on this album sonically there are songs
that are more traditionally country then
I put out before like hole in the bottle
and half of my hometown which is my
favorite song I've ever written and even
homecoming queen and then there's songs
like the other girl with with palsy that
pushes me and pushes boundaries but I
think it's exciting the album comes out
March 20th
[Music]
the outside was up for pre-order Friday
as well
the more I grow up and like own my
artistry and I own just who I'm becoming
and who I am I feel like I stand more
firmly and myself and that shows in my
songwriting in my music and so this
album is called healthy
[Music]